tucker carlson you may not like tucker
carlson i happen to like him but you may
not like him you may not agree with him
but the idea that the military could
bust into this guy's house and be and
detain him
for just sharing his opinion on what's
going on in a war
that apparently we're not part of in
another part of the world
dangerous dangerous stuff but you know
what don't take my word for what tulsi
and tucker believe so what exactly did
tulsi gabbard do did she call for a
violent overthrow of the united states
government did she come out and pledge
allegiance to putin
did she get a cyrillic tattoo on her
neck no
she didn't
what she said is we have a problem
here's how we know she cited publicly
available information and said we should
probably deal with that problem
but in case you're mitt romney who was a
consultant for god's sakes accusing
someone who's been in the army for
nearly two decades of treason
people didn't use to talk that way
treason is a death penalty offense
it's absurd on its face yeah she hates
our country because she's worried that a
pathogen might escape from a bio lab
and hurt people actually everything that
tulsi gabbard said as you know is true
it's not a republican issue it's not a
democrat issue it's a factual issue and
even in war truth is a defense in fact
it's the only defense is it true and in
a free country you can speak the truth
that right can never be taken away or
else it's not a free country what would
be your response to mitt romney
uh well first of all i think it's
important to point out here that this is
not a matter of disagreement or holding
a dissenting view this is about facts
and this is about the truth so while
senator romney and all these different
talking heads in the in the mainstream
media are regurgitating hillary
clinton's slanderous talking points
the facts remain number one is they're
accusing me of saying that somehow there
are bio weapons
labs in ukraine i've said no such thing
at any point i have said that there are
bio labs in ukraine that have received
u.s support that contained dangerous
pathogens that if those labs are
breached then then we in the world are
facing a potential future of pandemics
the second thing they're saying is they
deny even though there is a plethora of
evidence that exists they deny that
these bio labs are even there
which is shocking to me that you we've
heard over and over you've played so
many clips from people in the mainstream
media saying these bio labs these
supposed bio labs as though there's some
fantasy when over and over and over
again officials from our own government
department of state department of
defense and so on are saying
these bio labs in ukraine
have dangerous pathogens and we're very
concerned that they may be breached
all right so there is tulsi gabbard
calmly explaining
what she explained in the first place
what our secretary of state for
political affairs victoria newlands said
under oath to marco rubio that i just
showed you these bio labs exist
they are not bio weapons labs but the
question is if they were to blow up or
whatever is being studied there was to
be taken out and exposed to the world
what would happen
so mitt romney is lying the ladies of
the view are completely insane i don't
know what we're going to do about this
you know like this is this is just more
fuel for this sort of separation of
america that they live in an alternate
reality facts don't matter like facts do
not matter to these people because they
just lie they just lie and they call
them traitors and treasonous even when
everything that tulsi said was
absolutely true and it's just it's
russian propaganda if you don't go along
with what the machine wants it's not
just that you're a racist anymore you're
not just a homophobe or a bigot or a
transformer or anything else now you're
a russian asset and maybe we should send
the military to come get you